[Musique]
en France une semaine s'est achevée sur
la grève des mineurs sans qu'aucun signe
de reprise et pu être décelé
dans leur défilé au contraire les
mineurs ont confirmé leur détermination
[Applaudissements]
d'un bout à l'autre des bassins miniers
les trains sont demeurés mobiles et les
roues défausses n'ont pas repris leur
mouvement sinon pour les services de
sécurité dans les réunions qu'ils ont
tenu les mineurs ont fait de la levée de
la réquisition un préalable à toute
reprise du travail
[Musique]
les maires des communes minières de
Lorraine de leur côté se sont associés
aux manifestations et les orateurs se
sont préoccupés de la revalorisation de
la profession de mineur
et malgré les paroles apaisantes du
Premier ministre la situation au 11e
jour de la grève n'avait pas évolué
un mois après Bagdad coup d'État
militaire à Damas tandis que les chats
aux ordres du Conseil révolutionnaire
contrôlaient la rue c'est à l'ambassade
de Turquie que le chef du gouvernement
monsieur Khaled et lazem avait trouvé
refuge
reconnu par l'Égypte le Conseil de la
Révolution a manifesté dès le lendemain
du coup de force c'est sympathie prenait
précisément les auteurs du putchirak
l'unité arabe semble devoir être aussi
au programme de Monsieur salhabitat chef
du nouveau cabinet syrien installé par
les militaires
[Musique]
pour 10 états de l'Amérique du Nord leur
printanière du dégel s'est traduite par
l'assaut général des eaux hors des lits
des rivières et voici le drame qu'a vécu
de façon particulièrement Tintin c'est
un jeune habitant de l'Ohio heureusement
un hélicoptère veille
[Musique]
le jeune homme en fut quitte pour la
peur tous n'ont pas eu cette chance on a
eu à déplorer 18 victimes
à New York les eaux de l'Est River ont
causé la mort brutale de cet ouvrier
pénible bilan d'un fait divers peu
commun la chute dans la rivière d'un car
transportant les employés d'un hôpital
quelques passagers réussir à sortir
vivant de ce bain forcé du on le suit
par la suite à un accident cardiaque
survenu au conducteur
Edouard Belin Savin français n'est plus
sans doute le grand public ne s'est-il
plus ce qu'il doit se petit homme qui
habiter le démon de l'invention dès 1907
il inventa le bélinographe qui
préfigurait la future télévision à
laquelle il avait d'ailleurs consacré
des travaux c'est grâce à cette
invention que les clichés parviennent en
quelques minutes au journaux livré ou
transmetteur déjà mis au point en 1913
par Édouard Belin la photo transformée
en variation de courant franchit les
distances pour se reproduire sur le
bellino-récepteur
Edouard Belin fut le premier au monde à
transmettre des images à distance
[Musique]
avec le printemps la Parisienne change
de tête chez Serge Stern de large
mouvement souple et naturel
Henri menu dégage la nuque et cultive la
symétrie
Antoine Salvador reste fidèle au bain
d'eau alors que George Méry leur préfère
une certaine fluidité dans le volume les
mèches seront plus courtes avec des
mouvements mèches chez Pierre Charlie
plus contrastées chez Jean sarfato
c'est dans le cadre prestigieux de
l'Opéra de Paris que 40 mannequins ont
présenté les dernières créations de la
Haute Coiffure Française la tendance est
à la simplicité
le style aiglon domine avec toutefois
beaucoup d'interprétations personnelles
mais le drame est un parfois de passer
inaperçu il y aura toujours des
irréductibles
[Musique]
l'élégance du chef n'exclut pas le
velouté de la main pour le conserver à
travers les servitudes ménagères voici
une nouveauté présentée en Hollande le
gant a épluché les pommes de terre cette
paille de fer parmentière permet d'un
simple massage de débarrasser les
tubercules en tout genre de leur
enveloppe champêtre désormais se frotter
les mains devient pour la cuisinière un
geste fonctionnel voilà qui ouvre aussi
des perspectives inédites sur la
traditionnelle corvée de plus
corvée de printemps pour cette ambitieux
bavarois qui avec les beaux jours
espèrent retrouver la sveltesse de son
adolescence rien ne lui était épargné
pour tenter d'éliminer les disgracieuses
conséquences des excès de latin
mort à la cellulite pas de pitié pour le
bourrelet mais les kilos sont plus
faciles à gagner qu'à perdre et le
retour a des proportions à Pologne nés
sans doute pas pour demain
[Musique]
pas d'adiposité à craindre pour cette
athlète espagnole qui doit soulever 20
fois en une minute ce cylindre de 125 kg
un des numéros les plus caractéristiques
des escolaris les jeux sportifs de
Saint-Sébastien
celui-ci semble prendre un certain
plaisir à faire rouler des poules à
épaules une petite mappemonde de 200 kg
exploit digne du géant Atlas qui s'était
offert le luxe de soulever le globe
[Applaudissements]
l'épreuve de la descente du Candahar a
brillamment couronné la saison
internationale de ski sur la piste Verte
des Houches le mur une cassure brutale
de la ligne de pente constitue l'une des
difficultés majeures après de 100 à
l'heure le skieur est catapulté vers le
goulet
le goulet en voici l'entrée est un
passage étroit une sorte de gouttière où
tout freinage est impossible le
concurrent il peut suivre qu'une seule
direction celle de la ligne de plus
grande panne
[Musique]
troisième difficulté le chose de la fils
un passage en forêt ponctué de
nombreuses bosses qui secouent
douloureusement les musculatures déjà
éprouvées par 1500 mètres de course
telle est au-dessus de Chamonix la Verte
des Houches l'une des pistes les plus
difficiles du monde
seul un grand athlète pouvait remporter
l'épreuve ce devait être l'allemand de
l'Ouest ludwich lightnet
il avait eu la chance de partir en
douzième position c'est-à-dire avec des
conditions de visibilité acceptable sur
l'ensemble du parcours alors que les
premiers à partir au nombre desquelles
schrans la croix et Munch s'était trouvé
par moment en plein brouillard
[Musique]
remarquablement en jambe lightner
trouvait exactement la bonne ligne il
passait sans difficulté tous les
obstacles en s'efforçant de conserver
cette position aérodynamique mise au
point par les Français et désormais
universellement utilisés
[Musique]
dans la dernière ligne droite lightner
va rétablir miraculeusement son
équilibre un instant compromis
[Musique]
et c'est avec brio que c'est autrichien
naturalisé allemand va apporter à son
pays d'adoption sa première grande
victoire de la saison en dessin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
honoré Bonnel entraîneur des Français a
lieu d'être également satisfait il
classe très homme dans les 20 premiers
parmi lesquels Jean-Claude Killy 19 ans
qui prend la deuxième place
monsieur Maurice Herzog et les
spectateurs venus le lendemain assister
au slalom devait avoir le privilège
d'assister au récital de François
Bonlieu dans son style très personnel
tout délégance et de faciliter bon lieu
s'imposait de bout en bout une cadence
extrêmement rapide
[Musique]
c'est avec une bonne seconde d'avance
sur son ami peyriaque François Bonlieu a
enlevait ce slalom du candard bon lieu
prenait également la première place du
combiné ce qui lui valait la récompense
suprême le cas de diamant
[Musique]